plus de 200 entreprises sont réunis au
sky emploi l'espace showroom rassemble
les recruteurs sur des stands pour
échanger avec les demandeurs d'emploi
dans le secteur de la restauration le
stand elior est à la recherche
d'employés de service mais aussi de
pâtissier et de cuisinier il ya de la
demande
effectivement maintenant on se trouve
aussi face à une pénurie de postes
le chômage a pas mal régressé sur le
département du 78 de fait il ya pas mal
de gens qui sont en poste et ben il y en
a plus énormément qui sont disponibles
dans l'allée du service à la personne
on trouve le stand petit fils qui
recrutent 10 postes en cdi pour leur
nouvelle agence à voisins le bretonneux
pour accompagner les personnes âgées à
leur domicile
je petit fils on recrute des auxiliaires
de vie qui sont toutes des
professionnels qualifiés donc on recrute
des personnes qui ont un diplôme dans le
secteur médico social avec au minimum 3
années d'expérience auprès des personnes
âgées
notre principal autre critère de
recrutement étant le fait de pouvoir se
dire bah cette auxiliaire de vie
pourrait l'envoyer chez mes propres
grands parents le secteur de l'industrie
du bâtiment de l'immobilier bien
d'autres propose de nombreuses offres
il y a quelques années mayra rocher
faisait partie des demandeurs d'emploi
sur le salon aujourd'hui elle recrute
pour le stand century 21
j'étais venu sur le salon et puis on a
échangé on a discuté et finalement comme
j'étais je cherchais un poste en
alternance parce que j'étais en fait je
faisais une licence dans l'immobilier
bah du coup elle m'a proposé de la
rencontrer pour faire un entretien
d'embauché
pendant cette journée de recrutement
l'espace showroom situé au centre de la
piste du vélodrome présenter les offres
d'emploi sur saint quentin en yvelines
les recruteurs ont désormais toutes les
cartes en main pour recontacter les
demandeurs d'emploi qui ont déposé leur
cv